So listen.
How do you even do this?
Things are getting really ugly in the progressive
media space.
And it pains me to have to do this today.
But Sam Ceder.
Has casually made a disgusting claim about
the David David Pakman show and fired a shot
across the bow about our recent surge of subscribers
claiming absent any evidence, mind you, that
somehow bots that I have presumably used or
paid for are boosting our YouTube subscriber
numbers.
Let me give you a little background.
Last week, by the way, this is all a joke.
Just because I know people well, this is all
a joke.
Okay.
Last week, the David Pakman show hit nine
hundred thousand YouTube subscribers.
This was a major, major deal for us.
And we got from eight hundred thousand nine
hundred thousand in the matter of just a few
months.
And it was alleged that I established sort
of a race against Sam Ceder to a million subscribers.
That's very much untrue.
I didn't even know where Sam was from the
standpoint of subscribers.
What I established last week was a race against
the clock, not against anybody else.
I said, let's get to a million by Election
Day.
OK.
Now, we were not on track to reach that as
of last week.
We were projected to reach a million on January
9th.
Thanks to the last 10 days of people pounding
that subscribe button, churning that subscribe
button dremel, link the subscribe button,
you know, all of the battle of of all the
stuff we were updated to maybe be on track
to hit a million by December 25th.
This was apparently brought to Sam Cedar's
attention.
And in the midst of this, he has made the
sick, vile claim that we are using bots.
Check this out.
And indeed, it turns out we are just a few
thousand subscribers apart now.
It is totally plausible that either of us
could get to a million first.
And that's great.
I mean, in this case, you know, with with
trickle down taxes, a rising tide does not
lift all boats.
In this case, I think a rising tide does lift
all boats.
We get cross recommendations on YouTube if
more people watch Sam.
I get more recommendations from his videos.
If more people watch me, Sam gets more recommendations
from my videos, at least, presumably.
So that's my view.
But during a call to Sam yesterday, it was
disgustingly suggested by Sam that we are
using bots.
Take a look at this very ugly allegation.
I appreciate the message.
Ronald Reagan let Twitter battle die except
for four specific people.
So I appreciate that.
Yeah, one other.
One other thing.
Pacman is out there challenging you to a race
to a million.
You know, he's really coming after you and
he's pulling away.
You guys are basically tied around.
No, no, no, no, wait.
980000 YouTube subscribers.
He's already at nine.
Twelve.
And some people on Twitter were saying, well,
yeah, that's because Pacman does more videos.
But that's like saying the person who runs
the race faster wins.
And that makes the race unfair.
I mean.
I know this seems to be outworking you.
I smell bad.
I smell bots.
Now, this is completely irresponsible for
Sam to make this allegation.
It's actually sick.
And if I were you, I'm talking to the 900
and however many thousand nine, nine hundred
and eighteen thousand people in my audience,
Sam, saying that you don't exist.
OK, this is the epitome of depersonalization.
Sam is saying you you think you just subscribe
to my channel.
You think you're a person.
You don't exist.
You're a bot.
You don't matter.
It's like you're not even real.
Let's watch a little more because it actually
gets worse.
So look here.
Here it is right now.
I put this video up.
Look, folks, Ronald Reagan is just inform
me that David Pakman has taken a lead in our
race to get to a million subscribers.
And I am making a personal appeal to you right
now.
Hit the subscribe button.
It's not necessarily where I'm pointing to
I don't know where it is.
Maybe it's maybe it's down here or over there.
But hit the subscribe button.
Don't let David Pakman steal our valor.
Thank you for the reminder.
Go on now.
Yes.
He's stolen enough as far as I'm concerned.
But I'll go.
OK.
But also, yes, I think that you two need to
work out some steak.
And I was thinking that the loser has to you
the winner's promo code in their ad, in their
ad spot for like a month.
For a month.
So you would do the CBD.
You would do the CBD farm ad, but didn't say
coupon code.
Deepak man or whatever is his cool.
No.
Well, I wrote open code is left his best.
I'm not doing that.
I'll do the Sunday out out challenge though.
I'll do the sun's out guy wearing tank tops.
Yeah.
So Sam, they're raising the idea of a sun's
out, got a sun's out guns out challenge where
we wear tank tops and expose our biceps.
I don't know about that.
I don't know how much that resonates with
me.
But we can't allow this to happen.
Right.
I mean, after such a disgusting shot across
the bow was fired.
We can't just sit back and let them do this.
I hope people are with me here.
And then, by the way, it gets even worse an
hour later in the show.
Look at these dirty tricks.
I am for the sub battle.
I will make sure to unsubscribe from Pacman
to help you in the race.
You should tell your subs to do the same until
you hit one million.
No, I don't want it's not like Pacman.
Now, that's darker.
That's I that I wanted.
You know, Roger Stone here.
I'm not I'm not going to make a call for that
particular after I just read your call for
it.
So why would I do?
So that's even grosser, Sam.
Indirectly calling for people to unsubscribe
from me without really calling for it.
Right.
I don't have to.
I would never say that.
And why would I?
Because the caller just did.
Or the texter.
It's disgusting, guys.
So this just as a heads up.
This is all fake.
It's all a joke.
The only serious part is let's get to a million.
Helped me get to a million.
And Sam, help everybody.
You.
It's not like voting where you can only vote
once.
You can vote
for everybody.